[Music]
[Laughter]
this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash yeah dude
this is it episode of 124 finally we got
to episode 124 of congratulations always
been waiting for this episode you
understand and before we even start I
guess you know
let's do [ __ ] see where I'm gonna be
coming up we got the Tennessee dates
which are well first of all we got
Hoover Alabama on June 26th and we've
got Memphis Tennessee on June 27th June
28th Chattanooga now that's the name of
a place now that's the name of a city
Chattanooga Chattanooga is the name of a
city is it an Indian thing I don't know
sounds like it it could be but it's
probably not maybe it is but I'll be at
the to volley or the Tivoli theater I
don't know I don't these words were it's
like you don't know how they're
pronounced I'm not into them it's like
just have it be like everyone knows how
to pronounce car it's car even though my
Irish friend would say care and that's a
different word because care is another
word it's not car care is care see a re
and then I'll be in Knoxville Tennessee
which begins with the K which is [ __ ]
stupid right it should just be a no X
also over time we should have just
eliminated the K right we do that as
people we do that as people where we we
we you know the we don't have [ __ ]
tales anymore we used to have tales as
when we were fishes right we were
[ __ ] little beings in the waters
anyway do it I'll be in Chattanooga and
Knoxville and Memphis and Hoover so get
tickets at Chris D'Elia calm that's the
follow-the-leader tour that's a
follow-the-leader tour crystally economy
go check it out at wwe.com and it's the
tour he click on tour and he was going
he's all good
this is his ago so I woke up early this
morning and I had a meeting and I had a
meeting with with with Bryan Callen and
some other guys and my agent and all
that [ __ ]
Josh Lieberman you guys know you know is
the guy that sounds like that and then I
don't know look and so and and so Callen
always [ __ ] interrupts a meeting and
gets real boring in the middle of it
will be like on a roll and be like also
you know it'll be like also it's about
more than that it's about and you're
just like I'll for [ __ ] sake and I
just look at him and I say no man come
on and I'll say in the middle of Ian
well the problem is you're getting very
boring on you're about to get boring and
that shows some [ __ ] levity in the
[ __ ] meeting thank God I'm there to
literally save his [ __ ] and but we I
was just it's like I go to this I hate
having meetings at [ __ ] three arts
dude that's my management company
because there's a guy and the valet
where you first of all you don't need
the valet guy but anytime you there's a
[ __ ] lot and you don't need a valet
guy it's just like no no parking is fine
you got another guy to do a job that
there's another [ __ ] one at this
coffee place I go to and it's so
annoying that you get a ticket to get
into the [ __ ] place both of these
places you get their ample parking
spaces and there's a guy in the coffee
place there's three guys there's three
guys in the structure and they're just
sitting there and they stop and they
stop you
already you're driving to the spot and
they stop you and they say hey who you
here for and I just say I'm here to get
coffee and they go okay go up to the
next level which I already know because
it's closer to the coffee entrance so
then I get there there's another guy
there and the guy says where you going I
say I'm here to get coffee and the guy
says okay why don't you park right there
and points to one of the spaces that are
open and there's like [ __ ] 40 spaces
open I never Park in the one he tells me
because it's not it doesn't matter if
this guy is gonna make the [ __ ] job
more of a [ __ ] inconvenience dude
when they get people to dis is so
something I would drive me nuts people
that help you when you don't need to be
helped I have a question for these guys
my an elderly lady or my [ __ ] young a
[ __ ] dude I'm only 39 it's like crazy
how young I am I don't know if there's
anybody younger than me and I'm driving
in I mean I'm pre pedaling going [ __ ]
google gaga I'm so young I constantly
check for a diaper I'm so young I [ __ ]
my pants and I say it's okay I haven't
learned how to not do that yet so
[ __ ] young I am so you don't need to
help me park dude because there's so
many spaces now if it's a [ __ ] mess
if there's you know if parking is like
just if there's so many different cars
in the lot like [ __ ] what's that
[ __ ] [ __ ] the where they put the the
duck and the chicken and the ham in the
[ __ ] turkey and it's just like dude
what what are you doing what is that
called turducken
hey turducken go [ __ ] yourself
man you know how [ __ ] that is what's
wrong with chicken
what's wrong with duck what's our like
turkey dude
turducken is only okay if you put bubble
gum in it too and pepto-bismol otherwise
I ain't eatin it put it all in there put
it all in there you know how [ __ ]
both shitty it is to other animals that
would just rip them apart and stuff them
in another animal and then eat it and
then [ __ ] it out we just go all out of
our [ __ ] ass so gross dude
that's like if a turkey would [ __ ]
kill uh think about that what that would
be like if there were bigger beings out
there like Giants that would just kill
all of us white black Mexican and Asian
and then just stuff all of us together
and eat them they put it all in a
[ __ ] black guy and just eat it and
they just call it [ __ ] white blasian
and they just fight they just call it
[ __ ] white blasian white blasian and
the Giants are like did you eat wide
blasian today it's it's the day where we
it's the day where we conquer it all
anyway dude what was I talking about
parking I mean you know so and then
they're like yeah Park here I get so
[ __ ] heated do it in my car and it's
and how to make it look at this YouTube
video that won't fire pulled up how to
make turducken here's how you make
turducken you don't you don't
I want to make a video that's caught on
YouTube that's how to make turducken and
you click on it and it's just and it's
just me and I go like this
get down so I do that and then [ __ ]
and then so and then in the coffee shop
it's the worst dude because so just like
oh like this well I'm going to coffee
and they go like this okay they know to
they know what are you doing here guy on
the other hand it's nice that they just
have a job you know it's [ __ ] hard to
get a job out there so part of me is
like at least his [ __ ] company's
paying them you know what company is
doing this [ __ ] is what I want to know
anyway and then
and this valet one this this I don't
know if this browse me more nuts I do it
less go to three arts so I get to the
thing and it's always one of the gut two
or three of the guys and he's like
they're always like they're always like
when they're like how long you get a B
and I'm just like what the [ __ ] does it
matter I got to take a ticket anyway
what am I your [ __ ] girlfriend we
just talking and [ __ ] how are we in bed
so I say an hour and the guy goes like
this okay or I wanted to park there and
I can I parked there and I park where he
says because it's more official it's not
like a cafe am i all right maybe he
knows his [ __ ] every time I park there
and it's always a spot that's like free
and clear I'm not blocking a car and he
says but can you leave your key with me
which drives me [ __ ] nuts if I'm free
and clear why do I need to leave a cake
why do I need to leave a key if I'm free
and clear there is zero reason you need
to leave your key with somebody if your
car is free and clear okay so I give it
to him cuz I'm like all right whoa
what's the point if I'm like why well he
was gonna steal my [ __ ] my my
ibuprofen in my in my [ __ ] I don't keep
[ __ ] in my car so I leave and I come
back and the car is always in a
different space dude do you know how
[ __ ] annoying that is it's it's it's
pretty annoying I get back down and it's
pretty goddamn annoying dude that I show
up and my car's just in a different
place dude for zero [ __ ] reason he
just moves my car to another area for
zero reason dude
other cars are just in all sorted and
and then I gotta go back oh here you go
here's your key oh thanks dude thanks
for this nothing this guy's making
[ __ ] turducken in a parking lot for
no reason he making sure ducking in a
parking lot
young hope he's making young he's making
two ducking in a parking lot that's what
happens when you're bored with your life
you get cause you mismatched him in a
parking lot like you make it to ducky
Thanksgiving dinner get out your date
thing get out your dishes his
Thanksgiving dinner
[Laughter]
what's that like
get out you dinner we got guests coming
to Thanksgiving I love jay-z we'll get
so specific that you think he's actually
stop recording and like some real shit's
going on Thanksgiving Tina get out
dishes away
oh [ __ ] stop oh we know you're rapping
okay cool oh yeah
I can't say the n-word so oh yeah
these bleep is come and get out your
good dishes is something like he's
Thanksgiving first of all know for sure
get out your good dishes or something
send secure I mean then the next one is
and none other than there are and
without further ado I like like Freddie
get ready it's I mean just and okay
whatever button you know I need to go
all into that really but so [ __ ] make
you two attacking in the parking lot
yeah
jay-z send security laughs got to duck
in the parking lot hope I guess hope I
guess
did you see the video of Beyonce [ __ ]
just straight-up moding that girl who
was trying to talk to her jay-z and lean
over Beyonce and the girl was like at
the basketball game and she was one of
the [ __ ] Clippers owners or Lakers
owners or what of the [ __ ] who cares
want to Golden State Warriors owners and
she leaned over and and she was like
talking to jay-z and she leaned over
jay-z or Beyonce and Beyonce kind of
like shifted so she wouldn't
it and now here's what the annoying
people are saying oh yeah
Beyonce didn't like how she was talking
to her man no it's not that the lady was
just leaning over too much and that's
[ __ ] annoying a little bit sometimes
also there's probably the whole thing
more even though she was like one of the
Golden State Warriors or owner's wives
it was it still was like you know still
like where it was like [ __ ] don't act
like you know us dude you're not with us
you know so jay-z was talking back all
cool and Beyonce just kind of guy gave a
little bit of a look that was nothing
but then the [ __ ] beehive as they say
we're giving her death threats hey chill
hey Beyonce fans chill hey
also you call yourself the Beehive you
know in non-ironic terms look at her
[ __ ] just she obviously just kind of
is like what's up with this lady and
then just kind of [ __ ] shucks her a
little bit it's kind of cool dude cuz
the lady was just like leaning way too
far over her buddy who cares see that's
the thing
hey what are you doing that's what you
got to do don't shock she's Beyonce she
can't get get [ __ ] crazy with it I
was thinking about this like I was
thinking about this well I don't
remember what the example was but man
imagine being so famous
cuz you could only be so famous if
you're like if you don't say crazy
fucked-up [ __ ] and then if you do it's
because you're famous because of that
there's different levels of it but it's
like you can get as famous as like
Dennis Rodman was a lot of young people
probably don't know who they who they
who he is
but he was a basketball player that was
like famous for being crazy you can get
that famous but you can then you can
only if you're already really famous hey
turn it off
cuz if you're already really famous
you can't get and then you start doing
crazy [ __ ] like um like Charlie Sheen
you can't sustain that it's just
bothering me you can't sustain that for
it long too long like when Charlie Sheen
was like Tiger blood and winning like
that [ __ ] only lasts as long as it can
and then it blows over because it wasn't
famous for being crazy was famous for
being a famous actor or you can be the
like crazy famous but then you can't say
anything like [ __ ] Keanu Reeves or Tom
Cruise or Harrison Ford like if all of a
sudden Harrison Ford put out a video
that was like you know if Harrison Ford
all of a sudden put out a video like how
my video was making fun of [ __ ]
Armenians last week
hey if Harrison Ford was like how come
Armenians like love to say [ __ ] like hey
hey don't disrespect me people be like
Oh Harrison Ford is what the [ __ ] is
[ __ ] people be like [ __ ] arson Ford
for saying the [ __ ]
so like that would be my nightmare to be
maybe Harrison Ford's not the best
example but to be like that famous to
where you can't say the [ __ ] like it's
like Jennifer Garner like if she just
said that people would be like oh she
lost her [ __ ] mind dude
and that's to not be like that not be
able to say what you want to me that's
crazy that's so insane that that would
be the worst for me and I realize I'll
never you know be that [ __ ] the only
way I could get there to get as famous
that famous is to be because of aemon's
in the same person you know like it to
be a [ __ ] literal like if I did if I
had like a did it was a serial killer
then that would only add to it and he'd
be like wow this crazy [ __ ] comedian
who had a podcast and was talking about
how he made a cult literally started
killing people literally started killing
businessmen and killed [ __ ] 12
businessmen if I was gonna kill people
though it would be business men in suits
straight-up
nah
if they if they got other suit and I had
the knife ready and they're looking [ __ ]
together so I'm not doing it it will be
like live tonight at 11:00 talking about
comedian Chris D'Elia alive at 11:00 we
will be talking about Chris meeting they
wouldn't even dare disrespect me by
having new new news at [ __ ] 3:00 a.m.
that nobody listened to we had live with
3:00 a.m. we're talking about the
comedian turned serial killer Chris
D'Elia once had a spat with Albuquerque
and now has killed at least 13
businessmen with suits on I would give
all the interviews to I did I keep my
phone up my butt go to jail and [ __ ]
do live videos after that and you'd see
[ __ ] all over the lens it's gross that's
a gross but that's why you're here my
babies but like Tom Cruise was like he's
like so famous and then he did the
[ __ ] crazy like I'm in love I'm in
love you know with [ __ ] Katie Holmes
and then got like people started talking
about how he was in Scientology it's did
and they got a little bit people were
like whoa what's going on and then for
sure his PR told him to shut that [ __ ]
down because he stopped doing that and
then he just kind of was like okay well
let me just do ghost Protocol and take
out my craziness in how I am just going
to run across buildings with a [ __ ]
wire tethered to the top like like I'm a
tetherball dude Tom Cruise was a [ __ ]
straight-up tether ball in that movie
man ghost Protocol you know the name of
it huh Coast protocol I feel like that
Mission Impossible movie was the big
[ __ ] you was like okay you're gonna let
us get away with calling him whatever we
want let's see
ghost Protocol what was the [ __ ]
tweet that Delaney did Rob Delaney about
ghost Protocol it made me laugh so hard
it was when it came out he was like
alternate names that they were going to
use Rob Delaney and it was ghost
Protocol what were the names
is it down there it probably the top one
no right protocol to writing protocol up
there and that's 100% obvious one fire
let's just read all of his tweets that
say about ghost Protocol I bet he saw he
did Rob Delaney so funny I mean dude I
think he was on a tear with the movie oh
I us fight my dad the only actual the
only I love when he the only where did
it go
the only actual fistfight my dad and I
ever got into was when I said Tom
Cruise's hair looked cool as hell and
Proust gross protocol and he laughed
go down a little more oh here we go
titles considered for mission impossible
ah here we go click on that he wrote
I'll probably get impressed I'll
probably get in trouble for posting this
but I found a document at Paramount
Pictures that lists the titles they
considered for the new Mission
Impossible film before settling on the
excellent ghost Protocol please repost
in case they take it down from my site
Mission Impossible Loaf mr. impossible
plop
centrifuge centrifuge possible cont
Sullivan
Wow this [ __ ] is what the internet was
made for mission impossible beef
pamphleteer miss it impossible frost
debutante a lie kid said the next one
it's got the n-word in it Mitch
calibrate Fern gable tooth peach bottle
top North wiggle down [ __ ] blanket
squirt wow he's funny dude
that guy's funny as [ __ ] huh
it's annoying how funny it he is [ __ ]
passive accident more word on the man
call it Tom Cruise on Tom Cruise
Scientologist I think it's a privilege
to call yourself a Scientologist and
it's something that yet earn and because
Scientologist does a Scientologist does
or she has the ability to create new and
better realities and improve conditions
hey being Scientologist you look at
someone and you know absolutely that you
can help them well you know just [ __ ]
killing it at life I want to be like
that I want to just walk [ __ ] that dude
I'm gonna be Scientologist I want to
just walk into a room and just know do
you understand what I'm saying a blanket
[ __ ] knowledge of what the [ __ ] is
going on and I swear to God - oh not
only they laid that song over the
Mission Impossible song over this for
some [ __ ] reason but I'll bring a
[ __ ] straight up not iPhone iPod a
separate iPod with speakers that connect
and don't [ __ ] Bluetooth in and I
will [ __ ] straight-up play it case
while I walk in the room peace it's
something that
I don't mince words with that yeah we
know bro with anything I'm a
Scientologist Atwood policy to me has
really gone well how do I do it I just
done what I said you know what when I
read it to it yup I just went yes said
is exactly yeah there you go said
nothing and that's what I want to do
when people asked me about Scientology
and I'm focused right right now whatever
the first step is I did it made probably
realizing that you want to be it you
know that's probably what it is if you
look at the Scientology book they're
like yo first step is straight up
realizing you want it you need help
there we go
I'm on my [ __ ] way babies and I go
and I go like this and I go and I go and
people ask me about Scientology in
[ __ ] whenever I finish the program
whenever they get all their dirt on me
or whatever they go like they go like
now you're cytologists because you give
us some dirt and I go like this cool and
then people say what's up with
psychologists and I go like this dude
when I looked at Scientology straight up
the thing was it's like a light bulb
went off like I looked at it and I and I
read what it was about and at first when
I first saw it I was just like forget it
I was like forget it and then somebody
asked me about it and I was then first
time they talked about I was like what's
going on and they looked at me and I was
like you know what I know I know what's
up I walk into a room and you just you
feel it right he or she can walk into a
room and just feel it and I get very and
and that's the thing what's the thing
the thing is it's just you know it's a
being it's a presence it's an essence
where you walk in and you just you have
that because you've done the steps and
you've worked and now your mashed
potatoes and people are just over and
you're just like I know now your mashed
potatoes they're like well you didn't
really say much he definitely was mashed
potatoes that's the thing about
Scientology you know you know you walk
in and like a light bulb went off and
you first read those words you read that
and you know a light bulb went off and
you're finding you know that you can
help and and all of a sudden your mashed
potatoes and it's all good and they're
like way what and they get dirt on you
and your mashed potatoes if Tom Cruise
[ __ ] straight-up looked at an
interviewer and said I'm mashed potatoes
they would [ __ ] believe it
that's the [ __ ] thing I want to get
to all right here we go uh me undies you
probably spend about 90% of your life in
underwear so don't you think you owe it
to yourself to make sure you're wearing
the softest undies in town that's why I
only wear me undies straight up I got
him on right now let's look at what
color I was feeling gray
I was feeling great today I put on gray
because it matched my gray shirt me
undies uses the coveted micro modal
fabric which is a full three times
softer than cotton not only will you
feel like your loins are being hugged by
your by joy which is something that I
didn't write but it's true and my undies
gives you multiple style options for
both men and women and that's awesome I
do I have ones with bananas on them wink
you get it that's like a [ __ ] but I have
ones with bananas on them and they rip
they're awesome not I mean they actually
tear but they rip at life I love it men
can now try the boxer brief with fly
which is the same great cutters boxer
brief but now with an added option for
guys who prefer to go through the gate
versus over the fence sometimes you know
I do both sometimes a feeling one way or
another I play you can put anything I
take it out take it sometimes I take it
out under I don't even go over I take it
out under I lift the whole leg part up
and I go under dude I go under I Harriet
Tubman I go under to get your 15% off
look I get 50% off a pair are the most
comfortable undies you will ever put on
all right to get your 50% off your first
pair free shipping and a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee go to me on DS
dot-com / Congrats that's me on DS comm
/ Congrats shipstation when you're
selling online listen
getting your orders out can be a real
pain time-consuming it can be expensive
there's so many carriers to choose from
and how do you know you're making the
best choice you need to go with
shipstation comm it's the fastest
easiest and most affordable way to
manage and ship your orders and guess
what
I use it if you've received a dent shirt
from me or a Beggs unit shirt well it's
because of ship station
shipstation helps you get orders out
quickly save money on shipping costs and
keep your customers happy no matter what
you're selling Amazon Etsy your own
website shipstation brings all your
orders into one simple interface they're
really easy to manage from any device
even your cell phone so you could do it
there and they offer big discounts on
shipping costs and it's great no wonder
shipstation is the number one choice of
online sellers you'll ship more in less
time with the best rates available and
that's coming from me babies right now
congratulations was Chris D'Elia
listeners can try shipstation free for
sixty days when you use promo code
Congrats there is absolutely no risk you
can start your free trial without even
entering your credit card info oh look
at that they figured that out
just visit shipstation com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type congrats that's shipstation
comm then enter promo code congrats
shipstation can make ship happen always
be my maybe on Netflix is out now and
it's written in starring comedian Ali
Wong who we love who I work with all the
time and who is amazing and fresh off
the boats Randall Park who is hilarious
I talked about this movie with my mom
and dad and they won't shut up about it
they loved it they said how funny it was
and how great Ali was and I was like
guys I do stuff too okay but they loved
it they liked this so much my dad was
like that movie was so and he waited so
long to say the next word I was like
come on whatever it is it's either
awesome or what and he said good and I
was like wow it's good then if he's
waited that long you got to watch it
it's not your typical rom-com which is
actually what my dad said
it has Ali's amazing sense of humor
which is awesome because she's you know
great counter Yves makes an appearance
as himself and that's got my vote
because you know how big of a kind of
Rhys fan I am and I love him go to
Netflix now and add it to your queue
it's sort of right
certified fresh' on rotten tomatoes and
you know that's a good thing uh love
ally love comedies love romantic
comedies honestly the genre is killer
and always be my maybe streaming on
Netflix go watch uh cash app cash app is
brought to you by congratulations the
only app brought to you by me crystal
yet you know what I swear I'm gonna do
the episode where I'm just doing ads
that's gonna be that episode's gonna rip
just to get so respectful on you guys to
just do ad sixty minutes straight up of
ads and just in in no shirt drinking of
virgin my tire you know what that is I
just heard him heard about him what's a
[ __ ] what saw the one where you put
the leaves in it what's that one called
is that my time what's the one that
girls drink mojito dude remember when
girls figured out that thing like
[ __ ] four years ago they were just
like wait there's the mojitos and then
there they went nuts
wait this how you you know why it's such
a girl drink because you can put so many
things in it do you know what girls love
things girls love things they straight
up you know what guys guys like I don't
know guys that guys I don't know
whatever guys like this is what guys
like whatever this is what girls love
things dude if you could hold the thing
forget it dude
forget it tchotchkes you should see how
many [ __ ] tchotchkes my mom has how
much is tchotchkes sounds something like
it sounds like it's a racist thing is it
probably I have no idea I have no idea
all I know are tchotchkes are things and
if it's racist
come get me babies I've got no clue uh
dude my mom's got so many tchotchkes and
then she's got the nerve when she's done
with a tchotchke to be like hey Chris I
got some stuff for you come put this
chachki in your house [ __ ] [ __ ]
I got a whole closet full of tchotchkes
because I'm my mom life's hard
but what I'm saying is girls love things
and that's why my toys [ __ ] kick-ass
give a girl oh you don't think girls
love things dude
give your girl a bag full of [ __ ]
[ __ ] in it give your girl a bag full of
[ __ ] things in it
watch her smile dude she'll get chapped
lips your smile so hard so small so hard
that that [ __ ] [ __ ] on the bottom of
the middle of her lip it just goes and
then all of a sudden she's like I need
chapstick and you go check the bag
because it's in there because it's a
thing that's why girls love chapstick
dude they don't even like it why I like
to always keep my lips no they know you
don't you'll like it cuz it's a thing
that's what girls say [ __ ] let's fix up
an old car it's so you get the car and
what do we need the parts and oh we have
it good we have this stuff let's not fix
up the car I just really wanted all the
[ __ ] I'm surprised girls aren't hip to
those [ __ ] glasses that come up like
this yet they just like the real big
ones cuz it's more of a thing but you
mark my [ __ ] words girls are gonna be
wearing those [ __ ] in by next summer
oh yeah you know what by the end of this
summer I'm gonna put it out there girls
are gonna be wearing those flip up
glasses that [ __ ] corey haim used to
wear I swear to God because it's the
thing because they've got two things now
they got this part and this part it's
amazing how much girls love things and
they do and that's not a [ __ ] sexist
thing it's a [ __ ] gatherer thing a
hunter-gatherer thing guys go out and
get the things and they bring the things
to the girl and the girls [ __ ] put it
all in the house wonder what the girl is
who got the first thing was probably
some [ __ ] a a big [ __ ] bunch of
tied up sticks it's weird how that's
yeah a bunch of tied up sticks and then
they were like oh you can burn this and
it makes it cool scent and the guy was
like what are you doing with that thing
I you know it's usually for firewood and
he's like no no she's like no it's for
smelling and he's like that's not a
[ __ ] probably mean like it makes the
hut smell good alright okay
Jewelry there you go
BAM what do guys wear a tie or if and
guys don't want to guys are like I don't
know where the [ __ ] tie with a
[ __ ] tie you see a guy who doesn't
wear a tie wear a tie you see his face
bro
have you ever seen a guy's face who
doesn't usually wear a tie wearing a tie
it sucks
girls love to get dressed up though
let's do it
I mean not every girl you know but I'm
saying
girls are like I mean weddings girls
always like yeah we got to go to wedding
guys like a [ __ ] I got to go to
goddamn North Dakota it's so dick for
anyone to get married for real no it's
not thick to get married it's so dick to
have a wedding god when guys like your
sorry bro I gotta get married
you got guy you got come where is it
Hawaii yeah I get no no that would be
one where is it arts and [ __ ]
Michigan do it what yeah her family's
from [ __ ] Kalamazoo so we're gonna
have it over there so 90 people are
gonna have to go over there that don't
want to so yeah so I'm going to make all
of my family go to Kalamazoo cuz you
know why cuz girls like things that's
how much girls like things they'll make
you go to [ __ ] Kalamazoo because I
how much they like things so you got to
go and you got to dance the night away
dude you got to dance the night away and
you've got to trick yourself into oh you
know what this yeah yeah a good time I
didn't want to go but I got there once I
got there was never talked to that guy
[ __ ] that [ __ ] ass dude a real man goes
like yo did you have fun though was it
fun a real man goes like this
nope didn't want to go was there made
the best of it because I'm a human being
and didn't want to [ __ ] have to jump
but it was fine cuz I made it fine in my
head all from a girl because she loves
and you know what makes the world go
round things yeah man I always thought
about how girls like things ever since I
was a little kid I would be like goes
like things I'd think about that [ __ ]
what a weird [ __ ] kid I must have
been man
for real one time I was walking up the
side of the driveway and my dad was
filming me with one of those [ __ ]
remember in the 80s that used they would
have those video cameras that were the
size of a [ __ ] koala and my dad would
just be holding it on his elbow like you
worked for [ __ ] ABC News holding it
on his shoulder like you work for ABC
News do I know Anatomy yes
did I say elbow instead of shoulder yes
doing over and over yes don't know sort
of yes never got yes is it fine sure so
he was holding it up and and and he was
like hey guys what are you doing and
also my dad his accident was so much
thicker in the 80s like hey guys what
are you doing what are you doing what
are you guys doing and I was walking up
and I was using a broom or something to
to walk up the side of the [ __ ] like
a like it was a cane and I said I'm an
old myun and then I was you know like
six and my brother was two and my
brother's walking behind me and his
[ __ ] diaper we're just just a diaper
you know how baby how like two-year-olds
are world like a shirt and then just a
diaper like put [ __ ] shorts over the
goddamn you know I actually don't know
where I fall on that I don't know where
I fall on that this is like the first
time where I'm stumped I don't know if
it's kind of like if it's cool to
[ __ ] put shorts on over the diaper
because it's like you're covering it up
for society and you're being cool about
it or if it's like to be a [ __ ] boss
baby and just put that diaper on hmm
anyway he was walking up with a no cane
pretending like he had a cane
after me and my dad said what are you
doing and my brother said oh my knowed
me on copying me and I dude I was six
and I was like this [ __ ] is
copying me dude like I was a six year
old thinking that it's [ __ ] first of
all I remember thinking it's he doesn't
have a [ __ ] cane he's pretending to
use the cane this was my [ __ ] bit I
was pretending of being all the old man
and then he's behind me and he's doing
he's not even saying anything different
he's literally like oh I was I'm an old
man and and I wasn't in the shot after
when my brother said it but my
six-year-old eyes were rolling in the
back of my head for sure no doubt cuz
you get your own bit dude I don't give a
[ __ ] if you're to get your own goddamn
bit dude I'm talking about
Scientologists when you drive past an
accident it's not like anyone else
it's your drive past okay that's that's
that's that's what you do that's what
you do as as a [ __ ] Scientologist
which me and Tom Cruise are because dude
if there was an accident on the road I
would stop when you drive past an
accident it's not like anyone else
it's your drive past you know you have
to do something about it because you
know you're the only one that can really
help so because I do that I am in
Scientology dude do you guys get it Tom
Cruise and I are Scientologists I
[ __ ] every time I've seen a car
accident
I've stopped got out and helped
everybody I can even see dude I you
think I'm [ __ ] lying every single
time no matter how fast I'm going no
matter what road I'm on if I see any
accident from a 1 there where somebody
for sure died or a fender bender even if
somebody like kind of like is by
themselves but kind of rolls up on the
curb by taking a right turn I [ __ ] I
literally and they even if they keep
driving I pull I pull I make them pull
over and I [ __ ] help dude you think
I'm and it's not like anyone else
guess who drive past you know you have
to do something about it because you
know you're the only one they can really
help youth I do it one time I got a guy
[ __ ] hit another car it was really
light it was only 50 miles an hour and
he hit the guy and the guy bumped in it
goes honk and he got out and they both
got out and I [ __ ] was driving by
dude
I was driving by from the freeway they
were on a side street I pull I got off
the next exit I tried to find them I
found them I got them I got out and I
said is everybody ok
and they were like what and I said are
you guys ok and they said yeah it was
just like a little fender bender we're
gonna get each other's information and I
said ok is there anything I can do and
the guys were like no not really you're
not needed and I said I'm gonna get you
guys some coffee and I [ __ ] went to
the nearest Starbucks I got them some
coffee I came back and they were gone at
that time whatever but I [ __ ] you
know I drank the coffee myself but dude
do you think I'm [ __ ] exactly yeah
being a Scientologist when you drive
past an accident you understand me it's
not like anyone else as you drive past
you know you have to do something about
it because ok you know you're the only
one they can really help do you think
anyone else would have gotten them
[ __ ] coffee dude no do you think
anyone else would have stopped if I see
an accident I'm stopping if I you know
when you're at home oh you're just
[ __ ] you know in a cafe and you hear I
bro I you don't see me anymore when that
happens if we're at a cafe and and and
you hear are you better and you're
talking to me
you better stop because this
conversation is taking a hiatus because
I'm I'm running out of the [ __ ] cafe
and I'm looking her where the [ __ ] does
that sound come from I'm going where's
that gonna come from if you're like what
what sound I said did you hear the
[ __ ] screen says yeah I said we're
wanted to come from in there I think
that area and I'm running dude and do
you know why
I've passed you know you have to do
something about it because you know
you're the only one they can really help
okay
that's it that's that's what drives me
is that I know that we have an
opportunity
to really help for the first time if an
effectively change people's lives I get
coffee for people in fender benders
that's it
I'll get him whatever the [ __ ] they want
if I see someone in fender better I go
like this can I do if I see and you are
for [ __ ] sake Oh son of a [ __ ] I
[ __ ] can I get your information I
Drive up I say hey can I take your order
and they say what I say I'm going to
Starbucks I'm just trying to do [ __ ]
everything I can to help and they say uh
we don't need coffee and I say if you
wanted coffee what would you want and
then the guy would be like I don't know
maybe I would I would probably get like
a a venti like Frappuccino if they have
like kind of like with a caramel thing
and I would say I'll be right [ __ ]
back that's that's what drives me is
that I know we have an opportunity I
walk you to Starbucks and I say hi
and I wait in line and I'm [ __ ]
waiting I'm amped waiting in life the
lines long I'm [ __ ] amped I'm ready
dude cuz I'm a Scientologist dude and
I'm ready and I'm [ __ ] in line and I'm
just waiting and when I get up there and
I said I'm do it and I guess what I got
in my [ __ ] head when I'm when I'm
when I'm when I'm ordering when I'm in
line all day all day and I'm in line
dude and I'm just a number waiting dude
[ __ ] waiting dude and they go ahead
tenant say can I take your order and I
say yeah I'd like a [ __ ] Tatum
Frappuccino I did a birthday Frappuccino
and anything you got caramel on it and I
need a [ __ ] now I got a guy at a
fender better down the street and I need
that what's your name my name you know
what you put on the cop scientologists
and they say okay man just chill and I
say I will not chill I got an accident
down the [ __ ] Street and they going
okay cool and I'm watching the [ __ ] out
of them do it too dude they're [ __ ]
making the Frappuccino dude and there's
close-up shots [ __ ] of the
Frappuccino Pam and they're making this
[ __ ] and I'm watching them in I'm and
I'm low to I'm in the you know how
there's a glass thing and I'm right
above the [ __ ] lip of the wall and
I'm watching them like this and they're
so just and they're like dude are you
cool and I'm like I'm cool but there's
[ __ ] people out there that were in
offend
bender and then they go like this and
they go and then look at the drink and
they say cyant ah and they get to that
and I've already grabbed it and I'm
[ __ ] running dude and I say and I say
where are the straws and they point over
there and I say and I look and if they
got the paper straws I [ __ ] take a
bunch of them and I throw them in the
face of the [ __ ] employee cuz I go
like this it doesn't help Turtles and
then I [ __ ] run out if they got
plastic sauce I'm jamming the [ __ ]
thing if they don't I take the top off
and I'm running dude and when I say I
take the top off I mean I'd say I ripped
my shirt off and I'm [ __ ] running
dude and I go here are your [ __ ]
frappuccinos
and they go oh thanks man and if they're
gone I [ __ ] drip the Frappuccino all
over my chest and it's so and I mean
this from the bottom of my heart dude
it's so goddamn sexy that it's on real
and it probably causes more accidents
and
to really help for the first time
if effectively change people's lives and
I am dedicated that I'm gonna absolutely
uncompromising Lee there you go daddy
came and that's the words that we [ __ ]
Scientologists live by it is a hundred
percent and just to top this off if
you're listening to this and not
watching this he did this interview in a
turtleneck boom was that Hiroshima
because dude that's the [ __ ] ultimate
bomb dropper at the end of this you said
all this in a turtleneck hey dude that's
it that's how it ends one time I was
friend I was friends with the dude that
was wearing a [ __ ] car damn this guy
made me laugh
I'm not gonna say his name just buddy a
holy [ __ ]
one time I used to live with him and you
should talk like this ma'am
this is how we talk man oh you would
laugh like that
whoa and he would be like I talked about
before in the podcast but he goes like
this he says man one time dude he was
always trying to get chicks it was so
funny he's like married now and [ __ ]
I don't know if he has kids or whatever
but he was you know he's like a guy and
he was just like oh man oh man chicks
dude oh he would say like that he was so
he was a chef from Ventura California
it was unbelievable it was he couldn't
have been more from Ventura California
unbelieva he was from Ventura I come
from so hard his name was [ __ ]
Ventura that's what I should call him
[ __ ] him his first name was Mike he's
actually come [ __ ] Mike Ventura pet
detective
Oh homie anyway uh and he looked for
real like a serial killer like he had
this [ __ ] impossible look in his eyes
that was just like
you think of him in retrospect you
imagine all of his whole eye even the
iris and the pupil all of it in the
white part it's all brown that's how I
imagined him anyway he's [ __ ] damn
sexy too he was just a sexy dude girls
love to this dude cuz he just didn't
give a [ __ ] anyway anyway dude um what
was story was I telling oh yeah so he
was in Las Vegas was just man I went to
Las Vegas once did this story [ __ ]
made me laugh so hard I cried he said
went to Las Vegas once man and I was
walking around man cuz he had a
turtleneck on when we worked out I was a
goober turtlenecks bro you say yeah man
so I was in Las Vegas once I was just
walking around man and dude oh I sort of
God dude oh I was like you know we were
all trying to get chicks but like every
time I saw the hot girl walking around
in Las Vegas she was always with a dude
wearing a turtleneck and I was like man
yeah I get to get a turtleneck this was
in Vegas so I went I left the group to
get a turtleneck and I was like you did
and he was like yeah man all of these
girls had the [ __ ] hot had all these
hot chicks had dudes with turtlenecks on
me and I was like how many did you see
he's like I swear to god me and every
girl all with guys with turtlenecks so
get her like dude I got her like a wart
that night and I swear to God I got the
hottest chick in Las Vegas and he was my
favorite guy in my life at that point
that was the guy he usurped all my
family members and friends beforehand
that was due to no it was so funny to me
because I was like I didn't know if he
actually thought that it was for real
uh I didn't know if he actually thought
it was for real the turtleneck or if he
was in on the joke that's why I liked
him when guys when I when gosh when guys
who because I'm always I always like
feel like I know if someone is for real
or not but dude that [ __ ] was making me
laugh there's somebody comment it under
this mission possible under the
Scientology thing
you can skip to any point of the video
and still have no clue what the actual
hell he's talking about
orgs are there to help okay but we as
you know and also the public say we have
a responsibility it's not just the
warning signs this we can bring peace
and unites cultures let's skip to any
part that once you know these tools and
you know that they work it's it's not
good enough romp and play just do that
I mean that's what I want it to be okay
that's how I wouldn't you know there's
times I'd like to do that but my
favorite part about this video is that
it's cut together so you can't like
there's no interview questions I like to
imagine the interviewer either I like I
either like to imagine the interviewer
just like this just though the whole
time just like just stuttering like the
[ __ ] King's Speech like Colin Firth
just like iiiii
remember that where they put that in the
[ __ ] preview iiiiii and you really
alright guys we get it you know he
stutters Colin Firth [ __ ] killed in
that role I didn't see it but I know he
killed it and he deserved the Oscar and
I know he deserved the Oscar because I
saw a [ __ ] clip of a scene where he
was like and if you're [ __ ] trying to
kill it playing a part of a guy who
stuttered and do it that much dude hey
Oscar there you go
Golden Globe Award there you go actors
Choice Award there you go SAG Award
there you go n-double-a-cp awarded there
you go I know you're not I don't give up
we could get all the awards I want to
play a stutterer and straight-up be a
[ __ ] dude that's just dude I'll kill
it dude do you think I won't kill it I
don't give a [ __ ] dude I'll kill it dude
oh you put me in a [ __ ] movie where
the drama dude that's it it's over it's
over I'm gonna be the best actor around
dude and you know how people on set will
be like I don't know if this is working
and then that [ __ ] cuts together and you
see me just iiiiii that's it dude it's
like he really people talking about it
like oh so how's the shoot going yeah
you he's playing a stutter you know we
got he's really going for a man it's
kind of weird I'm not sure and then you
cut that [ __ ] together and the Oscar
goes to Chris the Ilia and I get up on
stage and I give my [ __ ] acceptance
speech I give my [ __ ] acceptance
speech and you know what it sounds like
when you drive past an accident it's not
like anyone else
as you drive past you know you have to
do something about it because you know
you're the only one they can really help
that's that's what drives me is that I
know that we have an opportunity and
to really help and they're gonna go
thank you very crystal a one for [ __ ]
the princes speech um so anyway life
rips babies life [ __ ] rips life is
what you make it you know what I mean
I mean I know that cuz I'm a
Scientologist do a life rips life rips
you just have to realize it rips and
then it rips that's it
life rips if you think it rips it
doesn't rip if you don't think it rips
if you start being like oh man my bag I
got back pain back yes did sometimes I
got a twinge in my shoulder yes
don't let it pop me down sometimes
honestly yes
but then do I stop sometimes and I
realized tomorrow might be a better day
yes and then do I wake up the next day
and do I feel better sometimes yes
sometimes no but then the next day do I
feel better yes and that is when I
realized that life rips yes and then
there's less start to rip even more yes
that's it my babies it's all about
attitudes and he stays drinking Lacroix
and he stays keeping turducken out his
mouth dude if I was on an island and
somebody was trying to torture me to get
information I would say no unless they
tried to [ __ ] put turducken in my
mouth and I'd be like okay okay I'll
[ __ ] tell you did it
so anyway anyway my point is don't
[ __ ] [ __ ] move my car around when
you're a valet guy for no reason you
want to do Long Island misconnections
now you want to do it now okay I roll
all right he's looks like he's [ __ ]
his eye rolling but he's not eye rolling
alright dude I see one do thing he was
and I said what's up and he's like all
right I mean be aware of your face one
fire you know what I mean that's the
other thing be aware have you ever seen
people who aren't I mean he's I'm joking
with him but have you seen people who
aren't aware of their face and they're
just doing [ __ ] like looking at menus
like this like bro what are you doing
with your face
I want to tap that guy on his shoulder
when he's looking at a menu like that
and I want to say hey your face is your
face what are you doing with I just want
to say your face your face and I want to
[ __ ] bounce cuz what are you doing
with it
you got one face buddy you got one face
don't make it do weird [ __ ] out in
public if you don't want it to be guys
who [ __ ] ah [ __ ] weird ass make
your face rip as hard as possible always
do too otherwise you're not gonna get
any girls wet make your [ __ ] face rep
as [ __ ] hard as possible all right
Long Island misconnections which I've
been told are so Long Island it's
unbelievable I hop you were my server at
IHOP in comic first of all comic is such
a [ __ ] like Long Island sounding
[ __ ] [ __ ]
tall brunette now I want you to hop on
me so [ __ ] clever you were my server
at IHOP in carmack tall brunette now I
want you to hop on me oh wow a [ __ ]
poet dude you got poets in Long Island
oh yeah I didn't realize there were
poets in Long Island until I read these
[ __ ] misconnections huh I hop you
were my server at IHOP and Carmack 12
brunette now I want you to hop on me did
not contact me with unsolicited services
our office the [ __ ] subject of this
one or the the title of this one free
Taco Bell at 1:00 a.m.
poor Jeff Station the fact that the name
Jeff is in there anyway
anywhere is hilarious I just pulled up
to the drive-thru and told you and you
told me you waited an hour to get your
food and they gave you a [ __ ] load so if
you offered me some shitload of it so
you offered me some you in a black SUV
and you said you worked at a restaurant
do not contact monsters were dude if
you're trying to hit on a girl
don't ever say [ __ ] load
that's like saying heaps you ever talk
to a [ __ ] Australian guy like oh yeah
heaps yeah heaps
I'll lock your heaps you know Oh [ __ ]
dried up you could be drinking a [ __ ]
bottle of water go back to keep it then
you go to buy drinking a bottle of water
it'd be like lucky hi how's it going and
the girls are psycho who I'm so into you
and you're drinking a bottle of water
Milwaukee heaps weird the [ __ ] me
water God with the [ __ ] more water
guy oh you said heaps and it dried up
all the [ __ ] [ __ ] and given the
water dried up so you got empty bottle
now if your truck dude if you say aye
dude I just [ __ ] like it I like a
girl I'd like to take you out you know
we can go somewhere get a shitload of
food by the first time effectively no
you have to do something about it
because there's anybody need any help
you know you're the only one that guy
just said you liked it like me a
shitload and I drove away and got an
accident
I'll be right back with your coffee I'll
be right back with your coffee wow this
song [ __ ] rips dude [ __ ] with the
guitar imagine playing this live
what is that even in there Wow Elmo but
before I love how they tried to make it
rip more the song already rips the song
already rips dude and they try to
[ __ ] rock around when I first saw the
first Mission Impossible and they made
that [ __ ] song with time I was I go I
was in the theater out loud I literally
go like this oh of course I already knew
it was gonna sound like and it did dude
[ __ ] yeah dude
I [ __ ] to this I make love to this
every time every single time I [ __ ] it
is I've made a kid um ok what's the next
one
one Janis Oh is there a more name that's
[ __ ] what do you call it then Janis
more Long Island than Janis maybe no
there's not honestly you know what her
hair looks like wondering what happened
to you Janis used to see you driving up
the block it's kind of Boston I can't
get away from it I was a neighbor a few
houses down did you move I don't see you
anymore hey know your neighbors hey guy
she didn't [ __ ] you didn't know her
cuz she didn't because you creeped her
out dude do not contact me unsolicited
services or offers you know Janis do it
every time Janis draw by she was like oh
there's that [ __ ] creep do not
contact me one solicitor property yeah
here's no one you cut my hair should
know her you cut my hair Saturday
morning you con meant it on my gold
chain to hood Long Island I would like
to get to know you and thank you for a
fantastic haircut
do nothing that New York the most New
York word is fantastic for real you
think it's not what it is oh it's
fantastic oh yeah you have a pizza at
[ __ ] John's it's fantastic you get
the fantastic dough your [ __ ] whip it
around it's [ __ ] fantastic man you
ever try to [ __ ] lumix cameras
they're fantastic
and they get a shot like no other you
never see a [ __ ] yeah I never see a
[ __ ] you never see a [ __ ] shot
like this you're waiting zooming in and
out it's [ __ ] fantastic
you ever see the walls over at the
[ __ ] Museum fantastic unbelievable
swear to God that Lake over there
[ __ ] you ever been a massive pika
it's fantastic it's beautiful it's
[ __ ] fantastic they got like two
three months of the year fantastic the
other month's also fantastic but I'm
just saying alright I guess that's it
huh
all right I'm gonna go you guys [ __ ]
ripped it dude turducken my [ __ ] if
you eat turducken don't you go [ __ ]
yourself what do we got this it a cash
app is brought to you by congratulations
make sure to [ __ ] download that I
don't know where the hell the thing is
but oh here it is
download the cash app for free on the
App Store Google Play market download
the Chris D'Elia app you can listen to
the watch you can watch the first little
bit of this podcast whenever I put it up
live before anyone else there's merch at
the store Chris D'Elia calm we keep on
restocking my babies you can go get gift
cards - for birthdays and stuff if you
know that they're a [ __ ] fan of the
podcast or whatever or or me tweet me
subscribe rate and review the show on
iTunes it really helps and get the word
out there dude we're always trying to
grow man this podcast we're all about
growing that's what we're all about
spreading the cult getting that log
cabin eventually you can tweet me up and
I got a I got a wait on announcing my
thing that I said I was going to
announce last week but I got something
coming out cool coming out cool and I
got it I think I got a few things maybe
I got to talk about but uh
sorry about that and thanks a lot guys
you guys are the best my babies thank
you very much see you when we see you
[Music]